about the The Voice Christian Bale no he
did it himself
yes he did but this time it's a
different version well like I said
Christians a great actor for me I have
required electronic manipulation of the
voice to do it I we kind of thought we
posited that he was a he was a famous
billionaire and so the people would
recognize his real voice and it would
give away his identity so that in within
the cow is an electronic device that
changes Batman's voice for him so that
he's not recognized so that it digitally
manipulates the voice so I performed the
voice and then Zak was able to change it
with a computer later on so I just
played the part and then you know I
watched the movie it's the voice is
different it's electro because we've got
a mic and I think it is a setup it's
just what it is it's not amazing it do
that do you do do you do the thing when
you know that it's going to do it but
you still do it you do it on top of that
you do it can you give us some like
lines sure sure sure you try it drive it
Amy out let's see it with the girl's
voice I don't want to q1 or something
taking my job that was really good
have a go Henry why not what would
Superman say
those thing and he's gonna baton been
bad and you know I was 24 years old I
mean I barely knew anything at all and I
have to go with this little ritual where
I go out I give the guy $20 to do like a
pantomime kung-fu at a West fight at me